Oh god, oh god, oh god. I’m trapped in the
Infinite Ikea! How long have I been here?
How can I get out? How can I survive
the vicious Staff of the Infinite
Ikea and work with the other survivors
in this terrifying, endless building?
Okay. Let’s start from the beginning.
Day 1. I’d come to this flat-pack nightmare with
my lovely wife, Brenda, to pick up some stupid
sofa she saw online. We could have ordered it in,
but me, being a cheapskate and a fool,
instead decided it’d be a dandy idea to
head in and pick it up ourselves - even though
I can’t stand shopping in these giant stores.
Of course, it didn’t take long for us to
get separated. I was wandering around,
just pretending I knew what I was doing.
Surrounded by unfamiliar people. Then…
Not surrounded by any people at all. Like the
complete doofus I was, I’d somehow gotten lost.
Just needed to find my bearings again and
then I could call Brenda to come save me.
But I never did find my bearings. The
hours went on, and I was still lost…
Day 2. My dominant emotion on
this day was nothing more than
sheer humiliation, knowing I’d been bested by
a damn Swedish furniture store. I spent the
night before sleeping on a futon, wondering how
I’d gotten myself into this flat-pack calamity.
I spent the day searching for food,
my confusion and exhaustion increasing by
the moment. For a while, I even entertained
the idea I might have died and gone to some
Nordic hell. That night, I went to bed hungry,
knowing that if I didn’t eat soon, I might
be found as a skeleton on a dusty old futon.
It can’t end like this. I can’t die on day 2…
Day 3. I continued my journey through the
labyrinthine bowels of the Ikea, disoriented
by the endlessly iterating collections of cheap
furniture. There was something terrifying about
the emptiness of it all, this affordable but
impossible to assemble void. Starvation has always
been one of the most horrific deaths, hasn’t it?
You could only imagine my relief when I saw
the figure standing a few feet in front of me,
dressed like a member of Ikea staff. I’d found
salvation! I’d found someone who could help me
out of here! But when I approached, I
realized something was horribly wrong:
This wasn’t a human being standing before
me, it was a monster. A being I’d later
come to know is called The Staff
by the many people who fear them.
It chased me, repeating, “The store is closed. You
need to vacate the premises”, flailing for me with
its long, frightening limbs. I only survived Day
3 because I locked myself in a closet and just
waited while it hammered against the wood
with its fists. Once the “night” was over,
it left, and I was able to escape.
Day 4. I was feeling some intense hunger pangs on
this day, not to mention the fact that I now knew
there were monsters out there, just waiting to
beat me to death if they caught me when the lights
turned down. Needless to say, I wasn’t in the best
headspace, and I didn’t have enough charge on my
phone to justify opening up my meditation app.
Then… I found Nirvana. I found the
cafeteria, stocked full of delicious,
warm Swedish meatballs. No food
had ever tasted so sweet to me.
And this delicious meal also gave way to one
of the most exciting new developments: Gloria.
Gloria was a veteran. She taught me
everything I needed to know at this place.
Even on the first day I met her, she felt like
someone I’d known for years. It was her that
took me back to her home in this place: A little
fortress made of Ikea furniture, filled with a
whole community of other people trapped in there.
It was like being allowed into the Garden of Eden.
Day 5, and it feels good to be alive.
I met up with all the different people
around the camp. They tell the most bizarre
and fascinating stories. This sounds crazy,
I know, but I get the sense not all of them
came from the same place as me. Different
Ikeas in different countries, or maybe even -
as nutty as it sounds - from different worlds.
One guy, Tony, who’s been trapped in here for
a year and change, and we got talking about
different vacations we’d taken on the outside.
He told me he was from New York, and I told him
I visited there once, and I loved going to see
the Statue of Liberty up close. That’s when he
told me that he’d never heard of the Statue of
Liberty. I didn’t know what to make of that.
Strange little details aside, I couldn’t
be happier to be there with other people.
The next step would be finding a
way out of here, and back to Brenda.
Day 6. Gloria and several others led me
out on our first excursion - Missions
where the goal was to collect more food
and supplies, and map the surrounding area.
I nearly jumped out of my skin when I saw a
Staff member standing in our path at one point,
and the others all just laughed at me. The
Staff member just stood there, placid and still.
Gloria told me that it’s okay, the Staff are
harmless during the day. It’s only nighttime
when they enter their pattern of aggression. So
as long as you don’t get lost during the daytime,
you’re generally fine. The team
often used string, like Theseus,
to trail behind them and ensure they don’t get
lost. It was clear they’d been here long enough
to work out systems for every possibility.
Felt like I was in good hands with them.
We collected meatballs and some rugs
to fortify the walls and headed back.
Day 7. This was the first night that we had to
fend off a full-on attack. Those monsters, the
Staff, came at us in huge groups, pounding at the
outside of our perimeter with their balled fists.
It was terrifying. As a way of fighting
them off, we tied Ikea kitchen knives to
the end of curtain rails and speared them,
one by one, until all of them were dead.
But they just kept coming. More and more and
more of them. When it looked like one of the
walls to the north of the community was going
to fall, everyone around me started to panic.
That’s when Barry, one of the biggest men in
the camp, grabbed a hammer in each hand and
when outside. He fought like a beast,
taking on Staff member after Staff member,
tanking hit after hit. It was something to see.
That’s when he took off into
the depths of the store,
drawing the Staff away behind him and saving
us all. We never saw Barry again after that,
but he’s the reason all of us made it past
day 7. Thank you, Barry, wherever you are.
Day 8. Gloria took me out alone today, on another
search for the escape. That’s when she told me
about her sister: She’d gone shopping in
Ikea with her well over a year ago now,
when she was separated and got lost in here,
just like me. I had a lot in common with her,
including my feelings of guilt for abandoning
my loved ones and my drive to escape and be
united with them. While we were out that
day, we didn’t find anything useful.
Gloria seemed sad but unsurprised. The Infinite
Ikea had its way of slowly grinding you down.
Days 9 to 17. Despite a rocky start, I was finding
my legs in the Infinite Ikea. I started to get to
know my fellow Ikea prisoners, I started to
understand and truly befriend them. We went
on expeditions pretty much daily, either
to collect new food, more supplies to help
build up our community, or to keep searching
for an exit. To me, it started to feel like
we were making progress, and that helped a
great deal to keep my emotions semi-stable.
But it wasn’t the same for Gloria. After all,
she’d been here for so much longer than me,
and she had her sister to consider on the outside.
To her, these routines I was becoming part of now
felt like a prison within the prison. She
was trapped. Had her sister forgotten her
out there? Had she been declared dead?
Were people even still looking for her?
And it was on Day 18 that it all got
a little too much for poor Gloria.
She’d snuck out of the camp at night, when the
staff were most active, trying to find the exit.
Sadly, that’d cost Gloria her life. There’s no
way of knowing what happened to her exactly,
but considering how bruised up
her body was when we found her,
it was easy to make an educated guess: She’d
gotten bum-rushed by the Staff and beaten to
death before she could even muster up a defense.
It was a horrible day to go. We tried to give
her as dignified a funeral as we could, given the
circumstances: Closing her up in a body-sized box.
That was the day I decided to stop just
trying to survive, and start trying to escape.
I owed that to Brenda, if she really had
gotten out. I couldn’t keep her waiting.
But I wouldn’t be alone. As it turns out,
another two members of the little Ikea community
I’d come to know were willing to risk
it all with me: A man named Kelvin
and a young woman named Vicky. They were
sick of just waiting around and fending
off attacks from the Staff, night after
night. They both told me they’d rather
die during an escape attempt than while
cowering under a pile of cheap rugs.
And so, each armed with claw hammers
from the Six-Piece Ikea Fixa tool kit
and as many Pruta Tupperware containers
full of meatballs as we could carry,
we set off into the great unknown… of Ikea.
We traveled for weeks, marking out
tracks on the ground with the MÅLA
mixed-colors chalk selection so we
never got caught going in circles.
One day bled into the next: Nights were spent
trying to hide in closets and bathtub while the
Staff hunted relentlessly for people just
like us. Every single time, we got lucky.
Until day 41.
Here’s something you need
to know about the Infinite Ikea: You’re probably
already aware, if you’re watching this, that the
24-hour cycle of night and day is dictated by the
store lights up above. But the space between day
and night isn’t a gradient here, it’s a cliff. You
can be minding your own business, when suddenly,
pitch darkness, and now the staff are on your
ass. That’s exactly what happened on Day 41.
We were in the middle of a kitchenware section,
surrounded by a few docile members of staff,
when suddenly, the lights switched off and they
went hostile on us. They look pretty goofy after
the initial shock has worn off, but believe me
when I say that these monsters can really pack
a mean wallop when they want to, and we received
a reminder of this unfortunate fact that night.
The staff swarmed us, repeating that awful
phrase, “The store is closed. You need to vacate
the premises”, while they struck and flailed at
us. If it wasn’t for our trusty claw hammers,
we would have been dead that night. Thankfully,
we were able to give better than we were getting.
We managed to kill a decent number
of staff members and then make a run
for a section with better hiding places.
Myself, Vicky, and Kelvin all stowed away in
a large wardrobe until we saw light filtering
through the crack in the door, like we were
rejected extras for some painful community
theatre take on The Chronicles of Narnia.
But while we survived that night, we didn’t
survive unscathed. My face was swollen from
a nasty punch one of the staff members
dealt me, and from the pain in my chest,
I might’ve been dealing with a few broken ribs.
Kelvin sprained his ankle during the escape,
and Vicky had a cut on her forehead from
when one of the staff members kneed her
in the face during the fray. You never
win these fights, you just survive them.
We made a temporary camp in the area
where we could rest and recover,
as well as shaking off the justifiable
fear of death or grievous harm that
dampened our resolve to get out of
this place. That took us to day 53.
Of course, food was always a concern. I don’t
want to romanticize what happened in there,
as much as I’m sure someone on the outside might
want to imagine this whole experience as some kind
of exciting, survival horror game. But I assure
you, it was less “survival horror” and more
survival and horror. Meaning not only are
we suffering from constant fear, stress,
and paranoia for our safety in here, but we
also need to keep ourselves fed and watered.
You’re just as likely to die from starvation
in here as you are to be beaten to death.
We went in search of another Ikea Kitchen,
where we could fill up on more water and
meatballs - your lifeblood in a place
like this. It took us several more days
of searching and hiding, searching and
hiding before we hit paydirt. By the
time we actually got our hands on the food
and water, we were starving and practically
coughing up dust. Those meatballs were
the most delicious food I’ve ever tasted,
and I could tell from their faces that
Kelvin and Vicky felt exactly the same way.
Though at that moment, I told myself,
if - no, when - I get out of here,
I’d never eat another meatball. It’d probably give
me war flashbacks - or, I guess, store flashbacks.
We filled up our Tupperware and shoved them back
into our Ikea Pivring backpacks. Then, we needed
to keep moving, keep searching, and keep marking
the ground behind us as we fanned out into the
great flat-pack yonder, avoiding confrontations
whenever we could. The three of us still had no
idea what insanity was waiting for us out there.
We had no idea that there were even more dangerous
things than the Staff lurking in the shadows.
Day 68. Of course, I kept count, writing it
down in my on the back of a JÄTTELIK coloring
book. Trust me, when every night could mean a
horrible death, you keep track of the nights. Not
a single one of them escapes you. At a certain
point, I think we all adapted, in our own way.
It was back to caveman times again, learning
to be like our primal ancestors, hiding away
from the dark and the monsters that hid there.
So it was extremely surprising for us to
get the most brutal attack during the day.
At first, I thought we were being attacked
by the staff during daylight hours, like a
bolt from the blue. That’s when we noticed
they weren’t attacking with their hands:
They were all holding kitchen knives, holding
us up like bandits. That’s when we realized
what had actually happened here: We weren’t being
attacked by the staff, we were being attacked by
other humans dressed like the staff, wearing
their hollowed-out heads like grisly masks.
They told us that we were coming with them, and
if we resisted, they’d cut us to ribbons. And
seeing as none of us were movie action heroes, we
thought it’d be best to do exactly what they said.
This was how we fell into the
clutches of Generalissimo Vardagen.
Day 69, but things were not nice. I don’t
know if I mentioned this before, but the
community I became a part of in the Infinite
Ikea after meeting Gloria was just one of many.
Nobody knows exactly how many people
are trapped in here. I’m hardly a martyr
for spending 68 days in there, I know people
who’ve been trapped in there for years,
who’ve given up all hope of escape
and accepted their lot in life.
They became the elders of a lot of these
communities, helping others adjust.
Though of course, Generalissimo
Vardagen was not one of these people.
Myself, Vicky, and Kelvin were dragged by the
strangers dressed as staff members into a fort
made of smashed-up wood, nailed together into
a huge, ominous structure. It was a far more
extensive structure than any of the communities
I’d visited or even heard about before in the
Infinite Ikea. It was a true fortress, guarded
by many more of those knife-wielding people,
dressed in the clothes and the flesh
of the staff. They looked like some
evil cult straight out of a damn horror
movie; I’d never seen anything like it.
We were dragged into a kind of
tent in the middle of the camp,
made out of stitched-together rugs.
That’s where we met Generlissimo Vardagen,
surrounded by his guards. I’d later learn his
namesake was a set of steak knives stocked in
the Ikea kitchenware sections - similar to the
knives being wielded by his gallery of goons.
The Generalissimo himself was dressed
like some absurd tinpot dictator,
wearing a silly hat and a jacket covered in fake
medals. His whole presence felt like a cosmic
punishment for daring to believe things couldn’t
get any more absurd than they already were.
His men forced us down onto our knees,
and Vardagen cleared his throat to speak.
“Quake in fear at the sight of this Ikea’s ruler,
the great and powerful Generalissimo Vardagen.
I have united kingdoms from the gardening and
bathroom supplies departments, and crushed
dissenting tribes in the office furniture section
to the West. If you wish to live, you will swear
fealty to me and join my legion of servants.
If you do as I say, you will be given safety
and security from the staff come nightfall. If you
do not bend the knee, I will have you destroyed!”
By the time his little spiel was done, the man
was red in the face and sweating profusely.
It was clear that, much like your average Ikea
shelving unit after a couple weeks of use,
the great Generalissimo Vardagen had a few
screws loose. None of us liked the idea of
becoming slaves to some flat-pack ghenghis khan,
so we tried to persuade him to just let us go,
telling him that we hoped to escape the store,
and with our help, he could escape, too.
That’s when we learned a sobering lesson: For
some people, life inside the Infinite Ikea was
better than life outside. In the real world,
the Generalissimo had been a twice-divorced
ex-salaryman with nothing to his name but
debts and regrets. But here, he was a demi-god.
A leader among the rest of us mere mortals. Why
would he ever want to go back to the world that
had given him nothing and taken everything?
Day 70 to Day 84. We were forced into weeks
of hard labor after that, toiling under
the Generalissimo and his gang of brigands.
The soldiers worked us like dogs, making us carry
food and furniture back to the Generalissimo’s
Scandanavian furniture fortress. One day bled into
the next. The best I could say about any of this
was that at least we were safe behind
the walls of the fortress at night,
so we didn’t need to worry about getting
murdered by the staff in our sleep.
However, tragedy struck again on day 85.
Kelvin couldn’t take the work anymore. One day, I
think his mind just snapped. He refused to follow
orders from the Generalissimo and his lieutenants,
even when they threatened him with death. Sadly,
that night they would prove that this wasn’t just
some empty threat. When night fell, they tied up
Kelvin’s arms and legs and left him outside the
fortress. We were just forced to watch as the
staff assembled and beat our friend to death
while he lay there, unable to defend himself. Even
in all the time I’d spent in the Infinite Ikea,
that was the most harrowing thing I’d ever seen.
But in one of the few acts of righteous
cosmic justice that we’d seen since being
trapped in here, all those months ago,
just a few days after Kelvin’s brutal
execution. Day 90. The day of the revolution.
While I’d love to tell you I started this,
there are no heroes in this story, I just happen
to be the one telling you about it. Some internal
conflict between the Generalissimo and his men
boiled over into a kind of civil war that tore
the fortress apart from within. Vicky and I
escaped, but in different directions. I like
to imagine she got out in the end, it helps me
sleep at night. But one thing I will tell you:
Generalissimo Vardagen found out what happened
to tyrants, big and small, when his closest
confidantes gave him the Julias Caesar treatment
with the knives from which he took his name.
I don’t think there’s anything wrong
in taking a little joy in that.
For days afterwards, I just walked. I
felt so empty, but I refused to just
lay down and let myself die. Even though so
much of the hope had been beaten out of me,
I couldn’t betray Brenda by just giving up in
here. It wouldn’t be right. It just wouldn’t be
right. The days ticked on, and nothing changed. I
had no food, no weapons. I was getting so tired.
Then… night fell, and the Staff started chasing
me. They seemed even more aggressive than before.
I couldn’t fight; all I could do was run.
I ran and I ran and I ran, not even looking
where I was going, as the crowd of staff
started catching up with me. Getting closer and
closer. I ran until there was a doorway before me.
I didn’t even think, I was just trying to get
away. That’s when I noticed that the store’s roof
was no longer above me. For the first time in one
hundred days, I was once again tasting fresh air.
That’s right, folks. On day one hundred,
I was out. I’d truly made it out.
This victory, however, was short-lived: A
group of about six staff members burst out
of the front door behind me, charging towards
me with ferocious speed. I couldn’t move,
all I could do was grit my teeth and wince,
ready to accept my death at what had otherwise
been the high point of my recent life.
What a depressing irony that would be.
But instead, gunshots rang out through the air. A
hail of bullets cleaved through the staff members,
dropping them to the ground mere feet away from
me, stone dead. That’s when I turned to see a
group of men with assault rifles and tactical
gear walking towards me. In any other situation,
this might have been terrifying, but right
then, it was the happiest moment of my life.
These men took me away from the
parking lot of what was now an
abandoned Ikea. They told me they were
from a group called the SCP Foundation,
and that I’d been declared missing for some
time now. I didn’t care about any of that:
I just asked them if Brenda had gotten out. If she
hadn’t escaped too, then this was all for nothing.
You can’t even imagine my relief when they
told me that Brenda was never even trapped.
She was the one who reported my
disappearance after I’d dropped
off the face of the earth in what she thought
was a perfectly normal Ikea shopping session,
before that building was shut down and
cordoned off under some less-insane pretense.
But Brenda was alive and safe, and I’d get to
be with her again. I have no shame in telling
you I cried, but I’d like to specify
that they were absolutely tears of joy.
The men from the SCP Foundation
told me that they’d give me medicine
that’d help me forget all this
after I told them my story,
and there’s no part of me that has a problem
with that. Some things are better left forgotten.
But before the SCP Foundation wipes it all from
my mind and I get to go and live with my beloved
wife once more, this was how I survived
100 dreadful days in the Infinite Ikea.
Now go check out “How To Actually
Beat SCP-3008 The Infinite Ikea”
and “Surviving Inside SCP-3008 The Infinite Ikea”
for more of this Swedish flat-pack hellscape!